starting this hour off Pennsylvania's
calling Brian's with us hey Brian how
are you not bad how are you doing Dave
better than I deserve sir what's up in
your world well first of all it's a
great pleasure to speak with you and a
blessing you to it Maurice the reason
I'm calling is my boys and I are
starting over and I was going to be
starting school in the fall but I was
actually wondering I heard you talk a
lot about going to school debt-free I
was wondering what sort of grants and
where I can go to try to get to that
point so I don't have to take out any
student loans the biggest thing that
determines whether someone can go to
school debt-free is that they select a
school they can afford that's the
biggest thing and people tend to not use
good common sense in ratio to their
budget on what they can afford
it's that total so in other words what
are you studying you're obviously doing
an adult program of some kind what are
you studying it's going to be
engineering engineering technology and
I'm going to be certified the Cata
operator be my associate okay so you're
doing that a Community College or Texas
actually it's a private school but so
far there's going to be about $20,000 of
um grants and uh for a single parent and
a couple other ones I can get that free
so far that's real nice uh depending on
what the total was before they took 20
off it was the she told me it was
thirty-eight thousand a year no for the
whole for the two years okay and they're
knocking 20 off that so you got to find
18 yeah is that what you find is that
right yeah and what do you make now I
make about thirty thousand who that's
going to be tough and so it sounds like
you're going to be working a lot of
extra jobs yeah that's what I want to
try to do
trying to change help my cut my voice
into the future interchange the like how
how old are your boys for my oldest is 6
4 2 and 11 months and you keep seeing
you and your boys where your wife is
gone
yeah see about last June she left it Wow
six four and one did you say anyone else
two and eleven months and you got your
hands full Durr who's caring for them um
after after that happened I went through
before last June I was really I was
really bad with my finances and I lost
my job last December 2014 so we got
behind on ground we actually got evicted
but thankfully my parents have been a
huge blessing and they're actually watch
them while I'm at work mm-hmm
are you living with your parents right
now temporarily then yeah it's temporary
we are so like it I just got a bunch of
stuff paid all so now I'm saving up
sitting at our own house that's time
all right well what I would you know
you're brave dude man you're fighting
through some really tough numbers and
tough life situations so um what what
how old are you I'm 29 Wow okay ah well
you're you're going at this the right
way the only thing I would tell you to
do is two things one is if you go with
the particular school you're going
towards I'm going to really pound on
them about even more grants and so forth
and go guys I make $30,000 a year I got
four boys there's very little chance of
me being able to pay the other 18 so you
got to help me find more than 20 and you
just keep just keep raggin just go down
there and make friends with the people
in the finance office and take them
doughnuts and coffee and hang out with
them and you know and your you know find
some spare time and just really get
those folks on your side and go hey
where they're saying way we really want
to help Brian get in here we got to find
him another grant we got to find another
scholarship no loans okay then the
second thing I want you to do aside from
that is
I want you to go shopping and I want you
to see if there's another place you can
get your cat undergraduate cheaper than
18k your cat associate and you might
find that and in other words if these
people start at 38 and knock off 20 and
it's 18 but you could have gone
somewhere else for 14 the deal they're
offering is not a good deal yeah I feel
and so go shopping start calling around
finding out where in the area I mean you
may drive 20 minutes further but start
talking to some of the Vote tech schools
in the area the community colleges in
the area a lot of those have associate's
degrees in cat and cat is a great thing
for you to move into it's a great field
some of your going to be very employable
you're going to double your income you
know you're going to do good with that
that's a good it's a good choice for you
it's a very marketable good return on
investment for you to study it's going
to be worth the pain in the butt where
you study and work all the time for the
next two years and living in your
parents house it's going to be awful
maybe a hard two years but you're going
to set yourself up to win in the future
so I really admire your course your
direction the the direction you're
taking is very smart very wise yeah
that's well that's one thing I picked up
his visa where everything is headed yep
yep you just gotta you know you can walk
through poop if you look past it right
oh yeah that's what you're doing man and
you just got to walk past it and look
past it and go down there where am i
walking towards where am I going to end
up what do I want to be whereas what's
the five-year plan here what's the
two-year plan and then you can handle
working two jobs and you know and your
mom going crazy with four little boys
and then she's going to before this is
over because she's a human and therefore
always oh my gosh bless her heart
you know I mean it's not going to be
easy for any of you guys but like you
said you're you're playing the win for
the generation change you're playing the
win for your boys and that's your set
yourself up to do that so I'm going to
do two things one is be best friends
with the people in the finance office
and find some more money to is look
think about what we can do for extra
money while we're doing all of this
which is the dreaded extra job it could
be something as simple as delivering
pizza
and then the third thing is I'm going to
go shopping and see if I can find a
cheaper way to get the degree in your
area because it's like anything else
you're like buying a car buying a couch
you go shopping you try to get the most
quality you can get for the least money
so session is no different than that and
it's not about the experience it's not
about how pretty the campus is for God's
sakes it's about what you walk out of
there in your brain between your two
ears after you write all these checks
and that's why you're going and that's
really the only reason you're going is
to get that and so we've got to start
looking at college for what it is I love
education I love knowledge because it
gives you opportunity but it's more than
oxymoronic to me that people in America
not you sir
but people in America are stupid about
education it's kind of funny when you
think about that it's one of the dumbest
things work that we're the dumbest about
education among everything out there
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show I want
to write a song I want to own my own
business I want to make more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
New Year's resolution is to make more
money this year to wish
you